oh my god you're amazing thank you hi
I've had a big year I have a couple
months ago I came out of the closet it's
gay for me the hardest part about coming
out was tracking down everyone from my
childhood so I could tell them they were
correct it's so funny after I came out
so many people from my past said that
they knew I was gay before I even
identified as gay like after I came out
so many people from my past or like that
I knew Rob Gleason was gay I knew Rob
police who loved peopie's I swear to god
there's a true story
Gleason was 10 years old he was playing
Little League I was like that kid right
there is gonna be a queer there was just
something about how he put the bat in
his mouth
that can I don't know why I do that joke
in a Brooklyn accent I grew up in
Milwaukee Wisconsin that play right
there is gonna be a queer you can tell
from how he puts the bat in his mouth
if you say anything into Wisconsin
accent you have to invoke God and then
end it with the words good for him you
know if down low boy wants to spend his
adult life going around putting baseball
bats in his mouth for God's sake that's
his god-given right good for him though
trying to try to embrace the gay
community I'm going to the gay clubs
craziest part of a gay club is the men's
bathroom because at a gay club the men's
bathroom is just like a smaller version
of a gay club it's like a gay club
within a gay club it's like what do you
want to do it again clip you can do it
in the bathroom okay you want to do
drugs go to the bathroom you want to
hook up go to the bathroom you want to
get an effect go to the bathroom you
want to go to the bathroom you go
outside it's a 24-hour diner across the
street recently I was at a gay club and
these three guys came up to me and they
said hey we're all gonna go into the
bathroom do you want to come with and
I'm I'm newly out I'm trying to make
friends so I was like yeah sure and then
we were in the bathroom they were like
hey we're all gonna go into the stall do
you want to come with and I was like
yeah sure and then when we're in the
stall one of them pulled out like the
tiniest little ziplock bag I've ever
seen and I swear to God I thought he was
gonna say hey we're all gonna go into
this tiny ziplock bag
do you want to come with but what
happened next is like the coolest thing
that's ever happened to me these guys
offered me cocaine Rob Gleason not the
kind of guy that gets offered blow okay
if anybody looks like an undercover cop
it's me and if I don't look like an
undercover cop at the very least I look
like a tattletale so I said no to the
cocaine I don't do drugs but I I want to
make friends so like I didn't leave the
situation I just stayed there in the
bathroom stall and watched as the three
of them did cocaine which is the most
undercover cop things you could do in
that situation there was one time when I
was a kid when my sexual orientation
slipped out I was 15 years old I was on
spring break in Cancun Mexico it was
just me and my parents and while I was
down there I met a girl who was also 15
it was just her and her parents so she
and I we became like Spring Break
buddies we did everything together and
one night we're at this dance club in
Cancun we've been sneaking beers and she
told me that while we were on spring
break she wanted to have sex with me and
I knew in my heart like I knew I was
attracted to boys but I'd never been
confronted like this and and I I didn't
know what to do so there were these
candles on the tables in the dance club
I picked one up and I held it between
our faces and I said I can't have sex
with you because I'm gay and then for
dramatic effect I blew out the candle
and like she just started screaming at
the top of her lungs and 15-year old Rob
had never told anyone he might be gay
Fitzgerald Rob admits sneaking beers he
freaked out I ran back to my parents
hotel hid out never saw that girl again
and for months I just thought that's
what happens when you come out of the
closet people just start screaming like
a maniac but I eventually figured out
was that that candle had been sitting
there for hours and when I blew it out I
showered her face with hot wax I glazed
it like it was a doughnut think about
that story from her perspective she's on
spring break
she meets a nice cute clean-cut boy from
Wisconsin she goes out on a limb and
tells him that she wants to have sex
with him and what does he do he says I
can't sleep with you because I'm gay and
then he sets her face on fire
[Applause]